To understand how data science relates to
epidemiology, it helps to go back and look at
John Snow, the first epidemiologist. John Snow was
a physician in England and he lived in the 1800s.
And he was known for being the leader in medical
hygiene and also a leading advocate for the use
of anesthesia which apparently up to that
point was not very common. But, what John
Snow is best known for is for having responded
to an outbreak of cholera in London in 1854.
And what he did was relatively unusual.
He decided to chart the cases of cholera on a map.
He put a little mark where
somebody has developed cholera.
If we zoom in on the middle part, you can
see that right there in the center is Broad
Street and there is a lot of cases next to
one another on the south side of the street.
He was able to go to that location
and determine that there was a water
pump there and that people were getting
contaminated water from the water pump.
He took the very practical step of simply
removing the pump handle from the water pump
so people couldn’t get water out of it anymore
and the cholera cases dropped off dramatically.
This is seen as the first step of modern
epidemiology or studying the origins and
patterns of diseases. Now we can do
something a little more advanced to
that as opposed to simply getting out
some ink and putting marks on a map.
We can start looking at digital information for
patterns of disease. For example, Google was
able to track the spread of flu by looking at
search trends for symptoms related to the flu.
Another project by Wikipedia did the same thing
except for more diseases and more countries.
Similarly, a third group of researchers could
predict a small but important percentage of
cases of pancreatic cancer based on Bing searches.
Interestingly, all of those use people’s natural
interactions with technology and the internet
to try to see what’s going on in their lives.
But data science can do more
than that with epidemiology.
One of the big tests of epidemiology is estimating
the prevalence of a disease. One research project
has estimated the levels of dengue in Brazil from
Twitter posts. What was interesting about that is
they were able to do it both at a very local city
level and at a country level, and they were able
to do it both in real time and prospectively.
Other researchers developed an app for
the smartphone called Flu Near You.
It asks people for flu symptoms, they report into
it directly and so that’s going to the source.
Another very common source of data is the 70,000
people who use the ProMED-mail mailing list.
And this is a news aggregator,
it brings together news stories,
it brings together public health announcements,
clinical observations and that is considered a
very high-resolution and a highly accurate
source of data that allows people to look at
outbreaks in one place or another because
people are specifically talking about that
in a professional environment.
And then also another project has been looking
at the high-resolution or very high information
and highly detailed data that comes from medical
claims, de-identified medical claims in the U.S.
as a way of tracking diseases by what people are
actually going to their doctor to go see. All of
these allow you to estimate the prevalence of a
disease either by using naturally occurring data
through Twitter posts or getting more specific
by asking the people or by asking professionals
or even looking at the specific reports of when
people visit their healthcare professionals.
Data science is also able to help predict
outbreaks of diseases which allow you in
turn to plan an intervention. One interesting
project has been looking at GPS data from phones
and that has permitted researchers to track
the geographical movement of people who have
been diagnosed with Ebola. These are people who
they know have the disease and they were able to
see where they are moving and that allows
them to design interventions to hopefully
contain the risk of the disease spreading
either by encouraging the people not to move
or by preparing the new locations to deal
with a person who is carrying the disease.
Next, other researchers have used remote sensing
and satellite images to gather data about the
physical environment, the animal movement and
the human interactions of groups of people to
estimate how many people live in places that
are known to have great risk for the Zika virus.
This in turn allows you not to just see how common
it is and the patterns of movement, but also to
see what sorts of movements and interactions
create the greatest risk and also what can
be done to help reduce things proactively.
Finally, one of these straight ahead data
science applications is that researchers have
been able to take historical data about epidemics
and the spread and combine it with a diverse
range of data to create massive simulations.
These are very computationally intensive,
to generate these simulations of outbreaks,
that allows them to estimate the
probability of various scenarios
and to design interventions that match each of
those scenarios and their calculated probability.
Taken together, data science allow you to go from
the very simple but extraordinarily effective,
of putting a dot on a piece of
paper to find where disease was,
to looking at the natural traces of Twitter,
to asking people specifically about their
information, to even creating really advanced
simulations, and all of them allow you to
estimate both the probability of disease, to find
the sources, to see how it spreads through time,
and hopefully to create interventions to
reduce the spread and the risk of disease.